te hace escasos 30 minutos al
expresidente Donald Trump ha llegado
aquí a esta Corte Penal en el bajo
Manhattan y ha entrado por una de las
puertas laterales de los juzgados en
medio de una gran expectación mediática
y cerca de 150 o unos 200 periodistas
aproximadamente y una gran expectación
social muchos detractores también muchos
seguidores de Donald Trump que hoy han
venido aquí a apoyarle en este momento
histórico la primera vez que un
expresidente se enfrenta a cargos
penales en este país hemos visto mucha
gente de ambos bandos tanto a favor como
en contra de momento las manifestaciones
y las protestas están desarrollando de
manera tranquila salvo algunos
enfrentamientos un par de ellos verbales
entre Defensores y opositores pero como
digo Aquí la seguridad también es máxima
hay miles y miles de agentes desplegados
en toda la ciudad sobre todo aquí a las
puertas de la Corte Penal en este
edificio está completamente rodeado como
podéis ver de agentes de la policía de
Nueva York que están colaborando muy
estrechamente con la policía judicial
también con la policía estatal con el
FBI sobre todo con los agentes del
servicio secreto que no se han despegado
de Donald Trump desde que aterrizó aquí
Ayer por la tarde como decía hace menos
de 30 minutos Donald Trump ha entrado en
este edificio y lo que sigue a
continuación es que se le tomarán las
huellas dactilares no está claro si se
le va a hacer esa fotografía policial o
no Porque las autoridades temen que
pueda filtrarse a los medios de
comunicación se leerán sus derechos y a
continuación se espera que espere
durante un rato en una sala en lugar de
en una celda como suele ser habitual
para el resto de los acusados y a
continuación el juez colombiano Juan
Manuel merchan leerá los esa treintena
de cargos a los que se enfrenta estaba
previsto que Donald Trump no hablara con
sus seguidores hasta que llegara a Mara
lago pero lo último que hemos sabido Es
que su equipo legal ha dicho que Donald
Trump el expresidente quiere dirigirse a
sus seguidores y a los medios de
comunicación cuando termine de escuchar
los cargos a los que se enfrentan